l' usine de la hague et talent à
l'origine de cas de leucémies dans le
nord cotentin le rapport rendu hier au
ministre de la santé de l'environnement
est plutôt rassurant sur ce point même
s'il ne conclut pas une absence totale
de risque les précisions avec hélène
verne et andré nice aura voici le
rapport censé apaiser la population du
nord cotentin le fruit de deux années de
travail entre les ennemis d'hier
industriels et écologistes qui pour la
première fois se sont réunis le résultat
scientifique peut apparaître comme
indiscutables je n'ai pas réussi à
montrer qu'il y a un rapport entre le
niveau de radioactivité que l'on trouve
dans la mer ou que l'on trouve dans les
poissons et les cas de leucémie qui sont
observés selon le rapport
le pourcentage de leucémie attribuable à
l'industrie nucléaire dans le nord
cotentin serait de 2 % le reste
provenant de sources d'exposition
différentes
au total cinq cent mille mesures
réalisées dans la région comme ici près
de l'usiné de la hague ont été vérifiés
des chiffres est une méthode de travail
validé par tous les experts du groupe
mais les interprétations diffèrent moi
je suis dans le doute je suis arrivé
dans ce comité j'avais des doutes je
pars mes doutes sont toujours les mêmes
mais je n'apporte pas de preuve
c'est vrai que je ne veux pas faire de
catastrophisme
je veux pas dire ses installations ses
installations sont dangereuses elles
sont mortels mais je ne veux pas me
forcer un discours rassurant
l'étude est une estimation incomplète
pour les écologistes
ces incertitudes ne gâche pas pour
autant de la satisfaction de la cogema
un premier travail scientifique est
aujourd'hui achevée les ministres
devront dire si le risque même faible
est acceptable